what is a woman Mr Mayor
well I asked that question knowing full
well that people have been watching this
who may have gendered dysphoria and may
you know have concerns in relation to
this issue it's going to be quite Direct
in relation to this so a woman when it
comes to biology and sex is an adult
girl
but there are some women who may have
gender dysphoria and you know trans
women can also be women as well
right so how do you feel for example
about the issue of trans women and
women's sport which many including me
think is grotesquely unfair
my starting point is dignity and respect
but it's a fact when you look at the
science
there is a massive advantage in relation
to some sports if you have been through
puberty for example as a boy man and
then you know change your gender uh then
so I think it's right that the sporting
authorities look at the science look at
the evidence because it's a massive
advantage